le procès de ta aboaf au tribunal de
créteil dans le val m'a dans le val de
marne renvoyé au 3 juillet 2020 le
journaliste de 22 ans réclamée à ce
report il souhaitait récupérer le
téléphone portable que la justice à lui
a confisqué appareils indispensables à
sa défense selon lui ta aboaf devait
comparaître pour outrage et rébellion
sur personne dépositaire de l'autorité
publique
il avait été interpellé lors d'une
manifestation de soutien à des
travailleurs en situation irrégulière
c'était le 11 juin dernier à alfortville
on écoute j'ai été arrêté j'ai été
violentée j'ai eu dix jours d'itt et et
j'ai été placé en garde à vue et c'est
moi qui suis poursuivi
par cet agent de la bac maxime demers
il a engagé des poursuites contre moi
c'est le téléphone qui a servi à filmer
mon interpellation qui contient la vidéo
et tout ce qui s'est passé et avec
lequel justement je pourrai prouver que
ce policier m'a violenté et que les
faits qui me reprochent sont totalement
faux toutes celles et ceux qui d'une
façon ou d'une autre s'opposent de
finalement à cette façon
des manuels macron de gérer le pays eh
bien oui les journalistes ont je crois à
mon avis à s'opposer à 7,7 cet
autoritarisme cette répression
le journal y sont des citoyens à part
entière et plus que ça le journalisme
est un contre-pouvoir donc le
journalisme ne doit pas être avec le
pouvoir il doit être contre le pouvoir
puisque c'est ça garantit un équilibre
dans la démocratie et je crois que c'est
la tâche qui est la nôtre et je crois
que c'est ce que je m'efforce de faire
tous les jours dans le cadre de mon
travail et aboaf est également l'auteur
de la vidéo off qui avait révélé les
scènes de violence impliquant alexandre
benalla emmène 2018
ils étaient des dizaines ce matin être
venus le soutenir à l'ouverture de son
procès qui me soutiendra donc beaucoup
moins que je viens écouter qui défend la
liberté de la presse principalement la
liberté d'informer même quand on
s'appelait pas au pouvoir
la formation c'est aussi une forme de
contre-pouvoir par rapport à une vérité
officielle par rapport à ce qu'on
voudrait cacher et des gens comme tabou
half le faut et quand ils en plus qu'en
lan les empêche de le faire en plus avec
des brutalités
ben je trouve que on devrait être
beaucoup plus d'élus peut-être que
beaucoup plus de médias devrait être ici
présents voilà pour défendre la liberté
d'opinion pour être solidaire plus
largement de tous les reporters
indépendants de tous les journalistes
qui font un véritable travail
d'information sur les mouvements sociaux
sur les luttes et qu'il s'agit aussi de
protéger tous ses journalistes là contre
la répression policière c'est pas
possible de laisser faire la violence
policière on voit contre la politique de
ce gouvernement contre la politique de
ce gouvernement au service des plus
riches
ils ont plus que une arme un outil
s'appelle la police et sa violence et sa
aujourd'hui que ce soit par rapport à un
journaliste que ce soit par rapport à un
syndicaliste que ce soit par rapport à
un étudiant un gilet jaune
cette répression d'état qui s'abat sur
tous ceux et toutes celles qui
contestent eh bien il faut dire stop et
il faut le faire à chaque fois qu'il ya
un de nous qui est convoqué au tribunal
pour parce qu'il s'appelle tabou off
parce qu'il est journaliste et parce qu
il
jouy lé pa le mainstream comme on dit
vulgairement dans le c'est à dire qu'ils
n'acceptent pas le discours dominant